honey is now with more on this
development the chairman of the
Judiciary Committee Virginia congressman
Bob good luck sir good to see you
welcome to New York
Deshawn great be with you and your
viewers anything I'm saying so far
before I get to this new information
that's wrong anything you think I'm
wrong on well we don't know everything
that's right yet and so it's absolutely
critical that we get all of this
information out but this is very
alarming and it is absolutely something
that the Congress needs to pursue and
the American people need to know about
the calls for transparency are
absolutely your mouths like they're
withholding my interpretation things
from Congress well that's how I read
this text that we have provided today
this text struck references 302s as you
know from the amount of time you've
spent on this 302s our reports filed by
FBI agents after they interview
witnesses and there were requested by
the Congress and struck is talking to
Lisa Paige and he says there are very
inflammatory things in the 302s we
didn't turn over to Congress because
they weren't relevant to understanding
the focus of the investigation that are
going to come out in a FOIA and
absolutely inflame Congress now why is
it that folks in the FBI make that
decision in the United States Congress
makes decision what is relevant to these
political branches of government last
time I checked and we do have oversight
of Congress and in particular of the of
these branches let me ask you this
because we're this is what we looked
they first talked of an insurance policy
I believe it's Andrew McCabe struck and
page that we've got they knew that there
was nothing that was going to happen now
Peter struck is literally exonerating
with James Comey Hillary Clinton they
start this in early May she's not
interviewed to the fourth of July
July first then we find out Loretta
Lynch profile and courage that Loretta
Lynch also knows nothing's going to
happen a Hillary
so we have commis struck Paige McCabe
and Loretta Lynch knowing nothing's
gonna happen an exoneration before
investing
is that common practice I didn't know
you wrote exonerations before you
actually did the investigation
absolutely not and it shows an
unbelievably contrasting approach to the
investigation of one presidential
candidate compared to the investigation
of the other presidential candidate what
about the hate that we see lo sum F
Trump between page and struck and struck
is up to his eyeballs in everything and
he even conducted the interview with
Hillary before call me then publicly
exonerate sir after 13 minutes and I
have been a speech where you'd think
he's going to indict her and he edited
that yet how many times taking out the
legal standard absolutely well they hate
Trump now he also was appointed by
Muller
all the Muller appointments are Clinton
Obama DNC donors there's no Trump donors
in there and then I look at Andrew
Weissman here's a guy that got it wrong
nine Oh decision in the Supreme Court
overturning him he held back at scopa
Tory evidence in a particular case for
Merrill executives go to jail for a year
that's overturned by the Fifth Circuit
Court of Appeals does that sound like
somebody that should have been hired by
robert muller and should this special
counsel be disbanded based on what we
know now it's very concerning about
Weissman and more than just struck on
this investigation but I'm not prepared
to call for ending the investigation I
think that there has to be transparency
about what's going on behind the scenes
and not what the investigation Trump
Russia collusion that we've seen I
haven't seen it nobody's seen it have
they I haven't seen it yeah all right
congressman's great to see I know you're
working hard on this last question I do
have a question rod Rosenstein did walk
into paul ryan's office that i know this
happened this is when we're coming up on
the deadline for the information that
led to the memo from the house Intel
committee that's interesting to me
begging Ryan not to release it as I look
at that behavior and look at what we
you've you've read the memo correct I
have indeed will I be shocked
based upon what you're talking about
here I don't think I should comment but
I will say this that it's very important
for the American people to see it
because it is a very important issue
that could should concern all of them
and we should have all fifty thousand
text messages shouldn't we I think the
text messages as long as they don't
contain anything about sources and
methods we don't want to put anybody in
jeopardy I agree with that will I think
be available to the American people and
I'm worth thrilled to get these new text
messages because it fits exactly exactly
into what we're talking about we've
already requested them today and we've
requested them unredacted so agree we
can make the judgment about what is
important in this investigation and not
the people who are being investigated
congressman we need oversight more than
ever I am really concerned that the
grave injustice and a great corruption
has happened not rank-and-file at the
very top a lot is happening we've got a
good Inspector General who as I said to
you on your radio program yesterday we
have other ways to find this guess what
he found him meet end and that is really
important and we got all four phones and
we got how many phones do you have I
have one he got it normal okay good to
see you sir